well that was awful
hi doggie you're gonna miss us while
we're in Europe I'm going to miss him so
much
can I get a kiss yeah that worked out
well
all right not to the airport
carry on
scary up my personal item personal time
so do you tell Joe currently
Philadelphia face my watch is before
sometimes we take off
so one thing I really want to visit
while I'm here is gas stations I'm
obsessed with gas stations and I want to
see cuz snacks they have I want to see
how they operate so it's kind of made
like one of our first jobs we're at a
rest stop I fell asleep in the car I'm
so tired
it is 1224 on June 20th I don't know why
I love the subsided for the rest stop at
gas stations thought for now it'll Park
entire
you made in soup a there
sorry I assume that means tomato
breakfast dinner lunch I've lost track
oh my god we've been traveling for 24
hours like 24 hours you know how do we
feel like I'm gonna need them I'm gonna
get this candy I possum I'm done how
does it mean is it a vitamin I get the
bike Wow made it I'm done volume I
wasn't sure I'm so tired
okay cool number six I'm getting the
look at your little meal the other thing
that wasn't all about you like the
ketchup is small this is while we're
going to gas six you guys we're going to
the gas station all right I'm awake
let's go let's go Jenny don't you slide
yes who do they say free kringles I
don't have some candy please yes I'm
over it was on D yeah liban it's Snoopy
Snoopy I got this mini chocolate chip
cookies and so into this gas station he
didn't really like this so I gotta get
it how do you say don't go
I don't know good curry Sony got some
items time to rest of the room and I'm
going to bed and I don't care what
anyone says I'm going to bed I need I
need my rest
holy crap I just got like teary eyes